[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Dan Le batard host of The Dan Le batard
show with Stu gotz one of the best most
popular podcasts the Dan Le batard show
with Stu guns available on YouTube and
wherever you get your podcast uh the
Dolphins gonna have a new quarterback
next year Dan
it's an excellent question I do before
we get started though want to just be
offended on your behalf at the profound
indifference of those sloths you have
over there when you ask them with great
enthusiasm after all these years who's
got it better than us and they belch out
something that has no passion in it
nothing like like if everyone's got beer
and barbecue on a Friday as part of the
work experience as if everyone's got
pigs in a blanket provided by Dan
Patrick you asked for them to show you
some enthusiasm and they just belched
out some mediocre exhaust I know you're
right they're spoiled Dan
the Dolphin fan base has been waiting
this has been an All or Nothing season
they went all in they traded draft picks
gave up salary cap space they've got the
best quarterback rating from someone
this young since Mourinho at quarterback
when Tua is healthy he has been
numerically a quarterback who has been
overwhelmingly good like in the Mahomes
category you could say its system you
could say it's coach and I've never seen
a situation like this Dan in all my
history covering Sports where this
quarterback is hugely polarizing
nationally the Dolphins have been a
regional team for 20 years nationally
he's the most polarizing quarterback in
the league and you really can go from
statistically he's the best to oh I
don't trust him at all I don't trust him
against San Diego I don't trust him
against San Francisco and again against
Green Bay when I need a game at home
he's throwing three interceptions in the
fourth quarter that he doesn't remember
member because his his head is not right
it is uh the whole franchise is built on
popsicle sticks like they have to make a
decision because the most important
thing is having value at quarterback
it's not just having a great quarterback
but it's having him so cheap that you
can put all the pieces around him in a
salary cap age the way the Seahawks did
when they were building around Russell
Wilson and you just don't know with this
guy you just don't know and I'm talking
about brain chemistry doctors whoever it
is you talk to franchise leaders you
just don't know if he's playing an
inherently violent game and these things
get worse as you go they become easier
to uh to have the more often you go and
he doesn't seem to fall right he gets
ragdolled a lot I don't it's not a good
answer Dan because I'm supposed to give
you a gas bag answer that knows but I
think in the dolphin organization
they're scared about not knowing the
answer to that question but could you
see a scenario where you keep Tua think
he's scheduled to make under 5 million
and you bring in Tom Brady
well the the most underreported story I
thought in America's most popular sport
last year was hey Brady's totally
conspiring and also by the way no Dan
Dan it's amazing that this happened
quietly it's just amazing Boston got
legitimately mad at Tom for only
thanking Tampa Bay without realizing
it's because he wasn't retiring like and
the only thing the only thing that
changed all of that again is a lawsuit
where the coach leaves because he's
saying that the team is racist that's
the only thing that ended up making that
all go sideways so I don't Stephen Ross
is desperate Stephen Ross is a laughing
stock one of the worst owners in the
history of South Florida Sports uh
because he has taken what was the
winningest franchise in sports the Miami
Dolphins and he has turned it into a
team that has not been relevant in any
way this Century he's in his 80s he is
used to winning he's not used to being
laughed at so I would not put any form
of desperation past him I don't know
what the relationship still is with uh
Tom Brady and the other people around
the Dolphins but it's kind of perfect
that they ended up losing a draft pick
and not even getting Tom Brady just with
flirting with Tom Brady and now they
find themselves in this super weird
position at quarterback where you have
more faith that Tom Brady can play a
healthy season at 46 than 2 again at 24.
how many concussions do you think Tua
had this year
I mean I don't I it's it's almost
impossible to answer he had the one that
we remember the most I would uh remind
people that Kenny Pickett had two this
year I would remind people that uh that
uh the center for the Buffalo Bills uh
Morse uh has had six in his career that
are documented and he just came out of
the concussion protocol but Tua has the
one that scared us before Demar Hamlin
to had the one that made all of us talk
about like well wait a minute I haven't
seen splayed fingers in front of the
face with seizure symptoms that's not
something that I've seen and then in the
the next game when he comes back I've
got my entire crew on our show worried
when he's on in the open field just were
just scared when he's in the open field
because of how we've been talking about
this uh no one has had concussions
covered more than Tua has and uh what
what one of the many interesting things
here uh Dan is how incentivized every
one is like this represents progress a
few years ago we wouldn't have been
talking about any of this stuff he would
have just kept playing and so this does
represent some progress but progress
still looks like hey there's a guy out
there who's throwing three very and easy
unusual interceptions to the Packers
because his head is short-circuited and
he's not remembering them the next day
because everything around him is
incentivized for him to try and keep
getting back out there and even you know
not telling the truth about symptoms if
his head is right enough to tell the
truth talking to Dan Le batard host of
The Dan Le batard show with stugots
available on YouTube and wherever you
get your podcast I wasn't watching live
but I did see a clip where Dan had Vince
warfolk on a former New England Patriot
time and uh you know Dan does his
research she's always very thoughtful
and sensitive and asking the right
questions at the right time doing his
research and um you know you asked Vince
about his wife and you always love that
Vince talked about his wife and very
candid about his relationship with his
wife and then all of a sudden
what happened
I don't know if your people have the
comedic uh sound that can be played on
what happens so you can enjoy the
delightful awkwardness uh on your own
but I and I also don't know how they
edited the end of it because I do
remember shouting at the end of the
segment whether they left it in or not I
do not know this would have never
happened to Dan Patrick uh just shouting
it into the into the distance somewhere
but the the short story is that I love
talking to Vince Wilfork 340 pound men
is stronger than anybody in in the
league about romantic things and his
articulation of softness and love and uh
the way he talks about his wife is
really beautiful unfortunately I was
unaware that they divorced
a few years ago the look on everybody's
face including the producers who
probably realized they maybe didn't do
as much research needed to and then Stu
gotz breaks the tension he tries to you
know clean up the spill in aisle six
there
wow the look on your face
when obviously
Vince goes Bianca and I didn't make it
yes and he starts talking about his
other and Danny got married in 2020. it
wasn't like October 20
th you're in a number of different ways
um it it could have gone first but only
if he had told me his wife had passed
away which is what I was what I what
what I was worried about but the look
that you saw in my face and I we do love
when these moments happen on our show
and we can sink fully into the awkward
disrepair but the look that you saw on
my face wasn't merely oh my God how
unprofessional of me and how awkward
this is but because I sort of associate
this Jolly big giant man with Romance
the look you also saw on my face was the
Heartbreak of oh no love has died not
just not just it wasn't his wife that
died which that fear came over me
um it's just love it's love has died and
Vince Wilfork is here to announce it to
me in the most awkward embarrassing way
possible can you guys play that do you
guys we just we played it last look in
it's a little too long now to play but
we played it about 20 minutes ago but
when you when all of a sudden I mean you
set it up and you know you're waiting
for that great answer yes it's a big
wind-up you know it's a full wind-up not
from the stretch position uh Bianca and
I didn't make it and I it's
funny number of different
different survive an airplane crash
if we did not we did not make we did not
make it this love you speak of so
elegantly damn I'm sorry to inform you
that it died three years ago and I
replaced it with another Vince Vince
lost 100 pounds and a wife
I I need you to help me though like what
are the I I really did shout that at the
end of that episode whether they ended
up putting it in or not I shouted this
never would have happened to Dan Patrick
so I ask you now as a a pillar of
professionalism as an exceptional
interviewer what are the greatest rookie
mistakes that an interviewer can uh can
make because uh the now I I would also
argue there has not been a better or
more memorable uh interview moment from
events will forth to interview in his
entire Hall of Fame career because uh
yeah because of what happened ends up
being wonderful because we can mock
ourselves but what are the mistakes uh a
that you have made that feel like that
which I doubt that you have or mistakes
that you know to avoid because you're
too Savvy well I I like to have an idea
of the answer before I ask the question
and it's really it's not a pre-interview
but I'd like to at least have a thought
of what is what I'm going to be asking
you
um and and really it's just kind of the
Bare Bones of knowing who his wife is
her name and how long they've been
married if I'm going down this road Dan
then I'm correct I've got to go okay
he's been married to Bianca they got
married
because if you do your research you're
probably going to find out that he got
remarried in 2020 yeah yeah if uh if if
that research had been done yeah but you
almost asked a damn good question but if
you did ask that question if you the
question was really good
but it you know he screwed up the answer
he's the one that got divorced man well
and the marriage both he's to blame for
uh
part was purposeful I'm not going to say
the whole thing was purposeful but I did
want to start there because as an
interview technique I don't need to
explain to you oh let's get this guy
talking about something away from
football that he's also passionate about
something that he doesn't mind talking
about to see if we can soften uh Vince
Wilfork up for later in the interview
unfortunately uh the softening uh is not
uh
the softening one of the things I love
Dan I don't think your producers would
react this way for all their
indifference about the pigs in a blanket
all my producers leapt into action to
laugh at me like they they they they one
of them was described as the guy on a
submarine that's sinking uh the that
immediately rushes to whatever it is the
emergency sonar stuff is because he's
been trained for this scenario all his
life like they just jumped in with the
ability to mock me instantaneously well
I would be concerned as I'm reading the
body language on this video
three of your guys are on their phones
they're not even listening to you do the
interview well no no no no no to if you
notice in the back Billy Gill the
anarchist Among Us the evil cat Among Us
what you will notice is he's not
generally listening he's pointing here
and there until he hears the mistake
then all of a sudden his headsets are on
and he flies in to tell stugots we've
got a maximum mock here immediately like
you see him jump into action like like
at the fire station when they do they
still slide down the poles you see him
he wasn't doing his job before then but
then he realized oh this is a good place
for me to do my job would you have
blamed your producer on the air
oh no it's just whatever it is that ends
up with me being mocked the most is
gonna be always uh always the funniest
but it was Chris Cody's fault yeah of
course
uh great to talk to you
it's always good seeing you Dan thank
you bud
we'll talk all right I owe you a phone
call you're terrible
you're terrible I love you too I love
you you can't be busier than me you
cannot I love you too good to you how
many kids how many kids do you have your
kids are grown
thank you Dan Dan levitar busiest man
I leave I leave phone messages I'll hear
from him three weeks later